these u.s soldiers are loading precious
cargo onto a military plane in germany
32 tons of baby formula enough to fill
one and a half million bottles for
hungry children back in the u.s we're
getting to help american citizens who
are
in need of help and you can always
depend on us when you need us
president joe biden announced the
campaign dubbed operation fly formula
this week several flights will take
formula manufactured in europe to
america after the u.s food and drug
administration lifted some import
restrictions
biden also invoked the defense
production act allowing the government
to more quickly restore formula to store
shelves i've directed my team to do
everything possible to ensure there's
enough safe baby formula and that is
quickly reaching families that need it
the most
this is one of my top priorities
biden has come under increasing pressure
to resolve the country's baby formula
shortage down about 40 percent from
normal supply levels the problem began
with pandemic supply chain issues and
grew worse in february when a major
formula factory closed due to
contamination issues
the fda says abbott nutrition's plant in
michigan is now safe and will resume
production soon but it could be months
before its product returns to shelves
it's been impossible to find
kim anatra is on the last can of formula
she has saved for her five-month-old
daughter like other parents she's had to
turn to imperfect solutions to keep her
baby fed she's giving her daughter more
solid foods though it's earlier than
what the pediatrician had recommended
it's been pretty difficult for us to
navigate now that we're literally on our
last can
the baby formula flights are just a stop
gap and it remains to be seen how
quickly they'll reach hungry little
mouths
heidi jo castro al jazeera washington